und es ist einfach wirklich ist es ein
richtiges abenteuer weil wie gesagt wir
haben einfach sehr sehr wenig geplant
also wir maximal so die eckpunkte
abgesteckt und auch das kann jederzeit
umgestoßen werden services und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
müssen wir wieder ein bisschen ins spiel
aufbauen
denn wie ihr wisst bin ich frisch aus
dem urlaub und kann eigentlich nicht
mehr so wirklich minecraft spielen zack
zack zack außerdem gibt's halt einiges
zu erzählen und zwar wenn ich euch heute
alle interessanten relevanten spannenden
knackigen taufrischen und tiefgefroren
infos zum thema roadtrip geben denn es
steht besteht in rottweil vor halo ist
genau die downloads büro für das wm ok
gut und zwar leute
kurzum anzufangen ich habe ja schon mal
so klein roadtrip gemacht zeitig auf den
gästen video mal kurz angeschnitten und
zwar der nach barcelona falls ihr euch
an den noch erinnert so könnt ihr das
gerne in die kommentare schreiben
interessieren und wir haben eigentlich
gedacht also ich mein kollege mit dem
ich damals schon in barcelona war als
gedacht dass er einfach sohnes in
barcelona das müssen wir unbedingt noch
mal machen also dafür alle die damals
dabei waren
das lief ungefähr so wir hatten nachts
um elf die idee dass sie mal ein
bisschen raus müssen in unserem kleinen
kaff und damals gefragt ja ok wohin
und da haben wir nachts um zwei bis
nachts um zwei jahren dann überlegt
wohin es gehen soll und danach zum 2 für
die entscheidung und der ort stand fest
es sollte nach barcelona gehen und dann
aufpassen losgefahren mit dem auto nach
zum 2 weil sich übrigens niemandem
empfehlen denn einfach 15 stunden
autofahrt nach einer durchgemachten
nacht sind einfach nicht witzig würde
ich ihn empfehlen aber es hat einfach
trotzdem bock gemacht das war einfach so
cool irgendwie ist auch schwierig zu
beschreiben dass ein einmaliges gefühl
wenn man so unterwegs ist man kann die
natur um einen herum vollkommen auf sich
wirken lassen
man hat sonst gar nichts zu tun kann
eigentlich vollkommen entspannen das war
einfach ein geiles gefühl ist es gesagt
haben hey das nochmal noch mal und
diesmal wird ein bisschen länger dauern
voraussichtlich vielleicht also zehn
tage ca vielleicht eine woche und wir
starten am 21
am zwanzigsten habe ich ja noch ein dreh
mit max moment lebe ich auch noch
richtig viele leute bei mir auch
28 habe ich noch ein dreh mit dem max
was dabei rauskommt werdet ihr dann auch
irgendwann mal sehen aber noch nicht
diese tage am 21 kanns losgehen treffe
ich mich mit meinem kollegen mit beim
kollegen und freund tom buhrow und dann
fahren wir los richtung den laden altern
eis lag alter schwieriger besonderen
server lag oder bei der auch in südtirol
wurde
ich weiß ja nicht er hat einfach drei
eigentlich zu krass segment hat
eigentlich zug rast equipment ich glaube
dauern
halo reach rohs blogs michael feiler
verschossen
ich glaube es ihnen einfach nicht mal
geguckt ja alter wie ja immer noch auf
mich drauf rage kleine equipment
[ __ ] alter du kleine kuba stamme ich
gehe
okay das war's mir das möchte ich nicht
nur 50 sekunden kann ich nicht weglaufen
glaube ich oder doch ja genau wie viel
herz noch egal wir in die nächste runde
und machen weiter mit den infos als
allererstes geht's nämlich nach berlin
45 stunden fahrt da werden uns dann auf
halten
für zwei tage wahrscheinlich von da aus
weiter nach hamburg von hamburg
höchstwahrscheinlich aus direkt nach
göteborg in schweden und die strecke
wird wunderschön das sei jetzt schon da
ich hab mir da schon auf google maps
angeschaut das wird richtig richtig geil
warum sage ich das eigentlich ja weil
ich mir nachdem ich letztes mal anleger
verloren habe jetzt eine neue kamera
geholt habe und jetzt darum gehe weiß
denkt frau noch ein araber kommt kimmig
aber du kleine araber [ __ ] da haben
wir wieder in der legria kaufen müssen
dies noch nicht da aber ich werde
wahrscheinlich wiederholen vielleicht
eine andere kamera aber auf den fall
wird eine kamera am start sein bei
diesem workshop und ihr werdet auch
sehen was wir dann zu sehen bekommen und
wir werden eine lösung finden wie ich
das von unterwegs hochladen kann
denk ich mal hallo frau freut mich
einfach immer noch diese kiel geilen
nutzen es ist einfach ist es nicht
auszuhalten
ich habe nichts was ihn irgendwie
interessierte gut mit technisch der ist
einfach nur horny auf den kill gucke mal
ihr wisst ihr könnt mit der wieder hat
ja dass eine angel ja hahahaha who
so wie immer werde ich für euch film
eventuell wird sich dann mein kumpel da
auch zeigen
der hatte sich ja in barcelona trip noch
nicht gezeigt weil das nicht wollte und
wollte nicht optimal
diese fucking die ihr [ __ ] das
gibt's nicht egal nächste runde kommen
eine kammer fünf richtig spielen und
dann was ab göteborg passiert ist
eigentlich vollkommen unklar
also was wir nach göteborg machen wissen
wir einfach noch gar nicht so spontan
sind immer in unserer planung
nur ein paar tage berlin dann hamburg
dann überall müll über kopenhagen nach
malmö in schweden und was dann passiert
das wird sich zeigen also das wird auch
für uns ein richtiges abenteuer und
deswegen glaube ich aber dass es richtig
cool lässt sich das anzuschauen
ich persönlich bin ein mensch der mega
ganz spontane aktion macht
glücklicherweise habe ich da auch ein
leck im spiel immer hallo hallo that
fucking lag alter glücklicherweise habe
ich da auch in kollegen der dieses
interesse erteilt und mit dem ich solche
aktionen machen kann habe ich recht froh
darüber
ja und alles in allem kommt dann am ende
eben in bottrop zustande und ich werde
mal gucken ob ich noch ein bisschen wie
locken kann also was heißt wieder wählen
kann
es wird auf jeden fall viel gewählt
werden also gefilmt werden was ich meine
damit ich will gucken ob ich wie long
kann ist dass ich nicht weiß ob ich noch
in der übung bin habe ich jetzt grade
jan eismann sehr schön aber ich werde es
einfach machen für euch und ich glaube
so cool
wir werden unseren spaß haben die beiden
irgendwie eine möglichkeit finden von
unterwegs hochzuladen so über handy
internet keine ahnung wie es oben ist ja
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr mit auf
diesen trip kommt und euch dort die
videos anschaut denkt das wird eine
richtig coole sache und es ist einfach
wirklich ist es ein richtiges abenteuer
weil wie gesagt wir haben einfach sehr
sehr wenig geplant
also wir maximal so die eckpunkte
abgesteckt und auch das kann jederzeit
umgestoßen werden können auch sagen wie
wir mittlerweile jetzt eine halben tag
in berlin dann sagen okay wir spenden
doch nicht in berlin sondern gefahren
über nacht nach nach meinem revier macht
kopenhagen oder kanal nach göteborg und
weiter den norden schweden weiß man
nicht aber es wäre cool was mich halt
nur abfahrt ist dass wir jetzt einfach
eine kamera kaufen muss man das tut mir
gerade momentan finanziell doch ein
bisschen weh ich bin momentan aber
überlegen ob ich dafür jetzt irgendwie
eine art spenden auf oder sind kraut
kermani crowdfunding startet für diesen
block serie
aber ich weiß es nicht wahrscheinlich
nicht weil er ist einfach nicht meine
art macht es nicht dann zeige ich lieber
selbst habe dann
wenig cola ist dass ich viel kohle ab
und leute angekommen war ihr habt doch
alle übrigen schätze ich schwöre ich
schwöre ich bin in dieser runde einfach
von den driesch ist so hart
ausgeschlossen
in dieser aufnahme bitte box durch das
ich abstauben kann bitte leute um man
macht einfach oder laufe wie dumm dass
dich aus der weltklasse nachwies
hormann es da unten drin aber das bringt
mir gar nichts er tableau ground scheiße
ja ach übrigens leute wenn ihr noch
irgendwelche fragen habt zum road trip
dann stellt mir die gerne in den
kommentaren
ich werde da rein schauen und versuchen
alles was ich da lese zu beantworten
nach bestem wissen
ich weiß momentan selbst noch nicht so
viel darüber nur das ist eine geile
sache wird vielleicht kenne ein paar von
euch ja die strecke zwischen zwischen
dänemark und schweden das ist nämlich
ich weiß nicht ob ich spielen soll aber
es ist eine ultra ultra kasse brücke
also es wirklich von malerischen ausmaß
was tt ich bin ich bin nicht alt
geworden was stt ich weiß nicht was der
titel her ist ist der garten blumen oder
hat es über die bedeutung obwohl timo
glocks blogs bobs ich ich ich könnte
jetzt aber diese und ich will die sonne
gewinnen
hoffentlich schaffe ich es
wahrscheinlich nicht er findet ihr chef
wollte die dfs jetzt gerade gelb gesehen
dann zieht sie einfach an
ja aber wieder leute alles was ich ein
feld zu diesem roadtrip gerne in die
kommentare und eine sache möchte ich
noch mit euch teilen
es fällt mir gar nicht so mega leicht
jetzt nach zwei wochen pause wieder in
diese in diesen aufnahmemodus
reinzukommen es irgendwie nicht so ist
noch ungewohnt momentan vorlegen ich
lese momentan halt relativ viel und so
dieser dieser sprung von danke pilz g
auf mich alter dieser sprung von ja ich
zum beispiel jetzt muss ich sagen was
und wo ich lese aber dass ein ernsteres
buch und dann diese sprung von diesem
buch dann das jetzt den ganzen tag
gelesen habe zu minecraft aufnehmen ist
irgendwie ein bisschen krass aber das
beschäftigt mich ja gerade einfach und
das teile ich mit euch ja als ob er hat
noch kann es sein oder wird einfach dumm
hustet er wird einfach auch jungs es ist
einfach mein team ich schwöre da was
passiert da gerade einfach niemand
stirbt
ich glaube dieser red hook und der
andere die team kann das sein
irgendwie schon hat das gefühl dieser
met you ich weiß es nicht es sei aber
komisch aus ok ok auf dem fall
vielleicht auch nicht wussten die sich
jetzt greifen sich gegenseitig an
oder weil es zu einem fast schon egal
ich werde auf ihn verfolgen dann werde
ich mir diese mit der altstadt
vorknöpfen
ich hoffe dass ich dann einfach mal
irgendwas geschalteten pumpen bekomme
aber ihr unten waren halt einfach ein
bisschen doof pech gehabt mit equipment
einfach so sagen so wie sieht's bei euch
aus greift ihr euch an die grenze
shanghai
ja könnte jetzt der welt raus pusten
nein
jetzt ist auf mich der andere täter
einfach noch da unten er ist immer noch
am leben
du wirst nie vergessen alter übertreibt
den bau gespielt er ist bei ihm aber
lockerte ewig viele pfeile locker alter
9999 ein junger was krass älter egal was
mit ihm passiert hat er sich ausgeloggt
oder bestimmte jetzt auf einmal was ist
los mit dieser runde einfach ich
verstehe es nicht
aber leute ich weiß das weil sich das
sechste game play es ging mir heute
einfach nur darum mit euch diese infos
zu teilen und so bisschen eure meinung
dazu einzuholen
ich hoffe ich verteile mir dass die
kunden jetzt nicht so gewann aber hey
ich glaub ich hab mein punkt rüber
gebracht und es wird auf jeden fall eine
coole sache wenn dabei sein wollt würde
mich riesig freuen uns wenn sicher
kohleblocks wenn einiges zu sehen
bekommen und zusammenleben also bis zum
nächsten video auf rein macht es gut und